how can I in a graphical way these are
both just graphic words show the kinds
of decisions that a decision supports
just a link based on some inputs right
like like what like these inputs what
decision you're going to make that's all
so it just looks a little unusual and
you may have seen some in the past
papers if you launch okay so let's
consider you went out for dinner and you
wanted to see what decision you would
make
after the meal was over okay so let's
make it really simple I'm just thinking
about two conditions that I want to meet
number one did the food comment I'm no
material taste good okay those are the
things I'm interested in right so food
prompt did it come on time and food
tasty what was the flavor level okay so
I'm going to do the table first and then
I'll show you what the tree looks like
they're both really simple okay when you
think about these two different
conditions there's a whole bunch of
combinations of ways that I could put
these two conditions yet
for instance the food could be late and
it could taste awful bad restaurant okay
so to symbolize that on my table I'm
gonna have some cells over here I'll
have one two three four you'll see why
in a second okay
was the food prod nor was it tasty no
okay now that's not the only combination
right the food could have arrived on
time but it didn't taste so great or
they could have made you wait a long
time but it was the most amazing satay
you've ever had or you could have gotten
really really lucky and you just to you
know year you hadn't even finished
ordering and then it was already
attention on the table and it tasted
amazing okay so here in my combinations
now on the basis of how these conditions
get met or not met I'm going to take
some actions sometimes it's best cause
decisions cause decision support system
but it doesn't matter now this is all
part of one big table
so imma prove all together now what
actions might we make well I'm just
thinking about this first one okay you
might want to complain you might say you
made me with agent tasted terrible I'm
angry okay so there's one of one of my
possible actions as a result of these
conditions because maybe you want to
tell your friends about this restaurant
or not
okay so there's another action you may
or may not take and you may like to say
I don't know if it was really really
amazing right you might go online and
you might write a positive review about
the place that you went to your personal
Facebook or whatever okay so let's just
go with those three now let's think
about how much for this can I fit yes
perfect
let's think about which ones you would
do on the basis of which conditions were
met okay so I got one two three four
right now first situation food late food
terrible okay I think I'm going to
complain right so yes I complain right
um I'm gonna tell my friends what do you
think I think I am avoid that place like
the plague okay don't go there I'm going
to write guru don't think so okay so
there's one set of actions that I'll
take on one set of conditions okay all
right three drives or times but done
tastes great
am I gonna complain where it's not
really worth it I don't think am I got
it to my friends well personally I
didn't think I would it doesn't kind of
raise an eyebrow for me it's like
whoever the food was so quick and tasted
terrible oh you know whatever okay we're
gonna write a good view not really okay
so I do nothing in this case if the food
arrives on time that doesn't taste good
as the food prompt no but it tasted good
well I don't think I complain because
the food was good but I'll tell my
friends cuz you know good food is worth
waiting for
I think I won't bother writing her
because something really really good for
me to do that my last one prompt tasty
not going to complain yes and no
telephones and I'll even go to have to
go online and actually types myself that
misplace right there that is a decision
table cause it's a table and it's got
decisions actions in it right and before
we go any further I want to draw your
attention to the fact that this column
in here he's right here he's kind of a
pretty boring column right
he's my do-nothing column alright so in
fact well why didn't I have one now four
columns across the top here you tell me
that's it but these are all of the
possibilities okay because two bits
maximum number is four okay but some
decision tables will not have all of the
columns right because ones like this
even though they're possible it's like
well yeah but you don't do anything so I
don't need to put any actions here okay
so I could just have equally have made a
three column one right and have those
options there or if there are three
conditions there are how many different
possibilities in total eight because I
get all of these and then another set
because it could be yes or no right but
I might not include all that I might
include just like three or five or
whatever however many actually makes
sense right now there's the tree sorry
there's the table let me show you the
tree again these are just graphical
methods of showing the same thing right
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
have the conditions oops that's a girl
just leave me color I'm going to have
the conditions running across the top
and I'm going to have the actions it's
terrible but running across downwards
okay
and what this is going to look like is
actually like last year's probability
sorry but thankfully there are no
fractions okay so I had two different
conditions prompt and tasty
question mark okay and I'm going to
leash your space here because these will
result in some actions now I'm going to
put some dotted lines in between these
not because I have to but because if you
don't I guarantee your tree will turn
out like a disaster like a lot of people
probability trees do in your name okay
so prompt there's two possibilities it
is or it isn't yes or no okay so I've
got two branches going like that so yeah
this is like you know probability and
then again for taste I've got two
possibilities right branch branch okay
now all I have to do is go up to the
actions that correspond it to those
conditions and then say okay well if it
was prompt and it was tasty what did i
do again well I think I told my friends
and I wrote a review okay what happened
if it was prompt but it didn't taste
good well I didn't do anything can
either write that or like I said before
you just eliminate that line if it was
late but it tasted good I told my
friends I think you're getting the idea
right but it's the same it's the same
information just showing differently yep
yep the reason that you might a separate
action before do nothing you know I'm
thankful because that's actually like
this it's it's something isn't it yeah
so to me um number one no no number two
usually it's actually that you get given
the table right
so you will not really be in the
position and also like you actually if
you don't if you have to get you get
rules and you have to make the table you
don't actually know if it's do nothing
unless the questions because if you
could it says there's an action that's
do nothing which is actually not an
action but have do nothing in there
anyway the short answer is no because no
action is the same as do nothing